(chimes)
- Informally, we can think of information
as some message stored or transmitted
using some medium.
When you paint, you are
representing your message
using a continuous pattern with a
seemingly endless number
of possible forms.
You are free to express yourself.
When humans began
developing writing systems,
we naturally had to divide our world
into a finite number of atomic units,
which we expressed using symbols.
Now any written language
can be thought of in this way.
Messages are formed by arranging symbols
in specific patterns.
Let's return to 3000 BC
and explore two ancient writing systems.
First, in ancient Egypt,
we had hieroglyphics.
A priestly form of communication
reserved for governmental, fiscal,
magical and religious purposes.
It was practiced by a select few writers
known as scribes, and
writing was generally
unintelligible to the common people.
The symbols themselves broadly fall
into two categories.
Word signs, which are symbols
that represent a single
meaningful concept.
- Back, apple
- And sound signs.
These symbols represent chunks of sound.
- Bee
- Zeh
- Tan
- Kah
- Now, the total number
of different symbols
in common use was over 1500,
and if you divide all of these symbols
into word signs versus sound signs,
we find a much smaller
portion of sound signs.
There were around 140
sound signs, and of these,
only 33 represented distinct consonants.
A tiny fraction of all
of the symbols in use.
At the time, the medium
used to store the symbols
was primarily rock,
and this was ideal for
durable inscriptions,
allowing messages to
travel into the future.
Mobility was not a main concern
when communicating messages in this way.
However, a new physical
medium for storing symbols
was emerging at the time.
Along the Nile, silk
deposits left from flooding
made the surrounding
land extremely fertile
and one of the many crops
they grew was papyrus.
It could be sliced into strips
and these strips were then soaked
(bell chimes)
and weaved together, and finally pressed,
allowing the natural
sugars to act as glue.
After several days,
it dried and formed an
almost weightless tablet.
This medium was ideal for sending messages
across greater spaces rather than
the more durable
inscriptions focused on time.
Now this shift towards
cheap, portable mediums
for storing symbols coincided
with the spread of writing into the hands
of more people for new purposes.
Gradually, as people began
to write more on papyrus,
the symbols evolved to
suit more rapid writing.
This led to a cursive
script known as hieratic.
For example, here is the world's
oldest surviving surgical document.
It's written in hieratic
script, dated to around 1600 BC.
Now these symbols were
based on hieroglyphics,
however the pictures
were simplified to match
the swiftness of writing
in ancient shorthand.
Also, the number of common symbols in use
began to shrink down to around 700.
By escaping from the
heavy medium of stone,
thought gained lightness.
A marked increase in writing by hand
was accompanied by the secularization
of writing, thought and activity.
This led to a new writing
system, called demotic,
around 650 BC, which
was devised specifically
to facilitate the ease of rapid writing.
For example, this text is
known as a marriage contract
and is one of the earliest
known examples of demotic script.
It's interesting to notice that there was
a dramatic reduction again
in the total number of
symbols with this new system,
roughly 10% of the total
number of symbols used before.
This was due to a shift towards the use
of phonetic symbols, or sound signs
- Bee
- Zeh
- Tan
- Kah
- over word symbols, or meaning signs.
And the new simplicity meant
that children could be taught
to write at a young age.
We see this same pattern
in other cultures.
Let's return back to 3000
BC and visit Mesopotamia,
where cuneiform was the writing system
originally used for fiscal purposes,
as it was a powerful
method of tracking debt
and surplus commodities
before the invention of coins.
For example, here is a document recording
someone's stock of animal hides,
and this type of writing
evolved to suit other needs.
For example, this tablet contains
a recipe for bread and beer.
And here's another tablet which
contains a legal document.
Now originally, the
writing system was used
by the Sumerians and there were over
2000 different symbols
in use, which could also
be divided into word
signs and sound signs.
Akkadian gradually replaced Sumerian
as the spoken language,
and here is the earliest
known dictionary from 2300 BC.
It contains word lists
in Sumerian and Akkadian,
and this was discovered in modern Syria.
When it was adapted by the Akkadians
and fitted to their language,
they reduced the number
of symbols to around 600
and they did this again by
moving towards sound signs.
Again, we see both
hieroglyphics and cuneiform
using several hundred sound symbols
in their more evolved forms.
And as writing systems
escaped their formal usage,
and spread to more and more people,
the soil was ripe for the invention
of a brand new writing
system for the people.
One of the great discoveries
in the history of writing
is dated to around 1700 BC.
The Sinai inscriptions were
found in the Sinai Peninsula.
and they were about 20 feet apart.
This was important because
each picture denotes
a consonant sound and
no word signs are used.
When sounded out correctly,
the letters would produce
words in ancient Semitic.
Although not fully deciphered,
this message appears to be of the form:
name, rank and prayer.
The two words deciphered
are chief and God.
This innocent example was
part of a writing revolution,
creating meaning by
merging sound signs only.
- Back, apple.
- By 1000 BC, we arrive at
the Phoenician alphabet,
which emerges along the Mediterranean,
used by the Phoenicians,
who were a maritime trading culture.
The Phoenician writing system
was based on the principle
that one sign represents one consonant,
and it was used to write a
northern Semitic language
containing only 22 symbols total.
These symbols chosen to
represent these sounds
were often borrowed for
hieroglyphic pictures
so that the letter's name
began with the letter's sound.
For example, Mem, which stood for water,
became what we know of as the letter M.
Aleph, which stood for ox,
became what we know of as the letter A.
But the secret power of this alphabet,
unknown to its inventors, was that
it did not need Semitic speech
in order to work. - B, C, D
- Ah, aye, ih, ooh, uh
- With modest adjustments,
these miraculous letters
would be fitted to diverse tongues
of Europe, India and Southeast Asia,
carrying literacy around the globe.
- Ma, da.
- This was the source of the Greek,
and later Roman, alphabet
forms we know today.
The idea of an alphabet
is a powerful method
for transmitting and storing information.
Realize it doesn't really
matter what the symbols are
or how you choose them,
or even what language it's in.
Information is just a selection
from a collection of possible symbols.
And over time, we've
always looked for faster,
more efficient ways of
transporting information
across greater and greater spaces.
And when we try doing
this using new mediums,
which travel faster than
any human or animal,
an engineering problem presents itself.
- Hello? Hello?
(buzzing)